I met Rasheed there as some breaking
news now about the company
um that owned the submersible uh Titan
that went down to uh the Titanic the
company Ocean Gate says that it has
suspended its commercial operations uh
completely it said it suspended all
exploration and Commercial operations
following the implosion of the
submersible last month while on this
Voyage to the wreckage of the Titanic uh
and of course all five people on board
were killed including
UK citizens Hamish Harding and the
father and son shazada and Suleiman
dawood alongside the Ocean Gate
Expeditions chief executive Stockton
Rush and also the submersibles pilot pH
najalay so Ocean Gate announcing perhaps
unsurprisingly in the circumstances that
it is suspending all exploration and
Commercial operations